I'm okay with Heights it was it's big
but you know when you're like yanked up
really quickly like 50 feet in the air
and there's just a man holding a rope
with your fate in it yeah that's a
little scary didn't you know Todd's
vegan
Scott get
hurt a lot in this movie by those guys
because they're so much bigger what did
he do this time no it's Scott it's
actually me on like hour 14 of watching
one of our poor fellow actors in a
harness I was really really happy that I
was not in a fight yeah but I am jealous
now that I see how cool it looks you are
incorrigible I don't know the meaning of
the word
I've never been in a fight over someone
I've never thrown a punch in real life
or been punched in real life I've been
tripped in soccer but that's just like a
heat of battle you know 70 Alexis yes
and I have to fight defeat defeat
there's seven evil X's if we're going to
continue to date pretty much I stay away
from conflict pretty much but I can
relate to Ramona I have had on a much
lesser level I've had you know like a
guy fight with another guy saying like
oh no I want to be with her you know in
like stupid immature ways
got here uh you know what he just left
I think that's the worst is when you
don't know what's going on and that kind
of happens in Scott Pilgrim you know
like with knives I know like Scott lays
her and he just disappears and she
doesn't really know why or like what
happened and how did she end up here and
so you kind of see her fight for that
hey I'm talking to you Scott Pilgrim
he's famous and he talked to me I've
always been a little musical but um I'd
never been percussive Kim
Scott Pilgrim is somebody that at the
start of the books and in the film kind
of has
maybe an unearned Cockiness but in
reality there's like sort of like he's
an absolute insecure mess it was pretty
Shaggy oh God I need a haircut don't I
and especially when he meets Ramona and
is forced to fight her 70 with x's he's
gradually worn down by the fact he's
outstripped by their sort of physicality
and musicianship and even sort of sexual
prowess Michael was like perfect as like
just that he could embody like the
goofiness the sort of the fragility and
somebody that you would it would be fun
to watch them being a badass because I'm
in love with
Scott earn the power of love I think the
sort of the central conceit of the film
is something that's really interesting
it's about you know having to fight for
your dream girl or supposed dream girl
so the idea of like you know going
through like the labors of Hercules to
win the fair hand of this kind of like
princess is really interesting and I
think really it's because it's
essentially a love story but it's really
about how much would you do for somebody
that you believe in or a relationship
you believe in and you know part of the
film is is Scott Pilgrim man enough to
actually get through this
program
[Music]